so today I'm gonna be talking about King
and pawn end games and hopefully we'll
get to switch topics and talk more about
some tactical stuff too
I looked at some games about 20 years
ago so this should be fun if we can show
them so this is the first time I'm
teaching this the King and pawn ins game
class so hopefully I'm not going to easy
or too hard so I'll be reading the chats
so just keep sending me your
combinations questions anything hi Kenny
alright so the first position that we
have is thinking about their rules so
this one is black to move I'm gonna
switch to flip the board so you have an
easier time thinking about it I'm gonna
be reading the chats on YouTube and so
just send me a line of first of all what
do you think should be happening what
are the things you should look out for
what do you think is the result gonna be
and ideally feel line in few moves in
one line
cool so I'm not earning getting correct
responses ideally for those of you that
this is kind of easy just let me know
what are the things that you're looking
out for for example double the answer
that I'm looking for here is a position
so ideally you would want to look at our
position and you would want to look be
careful about that and yep
Thank You robot Roland
sorry for the pronunciation okay so
basically we want to play king e7 to
hold that position and even if you lose
this pawn is perfectly okay as long as
you keep this opposition and you would
simply hold your ground thank you and
eventually it's attending a stalemate
alright thank you for all of you who
responded to me so let's go for the next
one this one is white you move and this
is another one of those super basic ones
that you should all have a very easy
time figuring out
yep so yeah this is watching and so the
problem is that you don't have the top
position and even if you manage to get
your palm to be seven king a seven and
after King C seven it's still nice
because black can't really go anywhere
so another way to think about it is if
you were to do anything else if even
right now it was black - black would
simply just play king c8 so if this was
black steel black we'll just play King
c8 and black would still hold the draw
so yep I'm getting a suggestion from
Paul about King d7 so even if you were
to play King d7 just King b7 is holding
it
I'm curious King eight how would you
want to continue because if king c7
still a position and draws are if king
c8 opposition still still needs Kingston
seven still again still mate
so you don't really have any way of
breaking in and one of those really
important things in endgame especially
in pawn king and panin game is being
able to break in and in this situation
you don't really have that chance thank
you so the next one and yeah so this is
what I was talking about if it was black
to move black would just play king c8
and hold the draw so now this one is
white you move it's still pretty easy
but just a really good warm-up so please
do a little bit of calculation send me a
line and preferably sends me the result
that your think is going to happen and
we'll go from there
I am reading the chats so
[Music]
again heads up to everybody I do have
problem pronounciating so I apologize in
advance
okay so I'm getting first suggestion of
draw from chubby chubby tourism begin
I'm sorry for the pronunciations so the
first thing that you should think about
is just looking at the position you
should automatically realize that this
pawn is under attack for black and the
first things that you should consider
should be taking this pawn I did with
the king or the pawn so the problem is
if you take it with the king black king
is close enough to be able to get to a
eight for example like this so taking
with the king
doesn't really make any logical sense
because you'd have them you would have
no way of park making a progress if your
king was for example on b6 this position
is winning because your king is kind of
like holding blacks King away so you can
make a queen but that is not realistic
in this position so the first note that
you should automatically know by
elimination of other moves is taking the
pawn back with the pond and after for
example King d6
how would you want to bring your King in
because if you play King c4 there's king
c6 and then there's opposition so I'm
getting different lines I'm going to
read over those right now so the first
one I have a before King a for King a5
yes I think that's the correct way to go
forward Paul is giving a little bit more
detailed line of King a4 and King a5 yes
mr. mani low C is also correct
Brandon is also correct so yeah
basically you wouldn't want to bring
your king to c4 because this would take
away any chance of basically tricking
your opponents and being able to get
into getting your King in there to
protect the pathway for the pawn so can
get a four kings day six
now you bring your king to a5 now black
is kind of stuck if black plays King c7
you can simply play King e6 king c6 you
just give the check and you just this is
totally when you because your king is
protecting all of the squares that the
upon is going to go to so King c7
doesn't work if King b7 you would simply
play king b5 hold that position king c7
now King a6 King b8 king b6 so the most
important thing is for you to not start
rushing the pawn because I know it's a
very basic concept and we all try not to
do it and we've all heard about it
before but it's really important to
really know that the difference between
half a pointer the full point is for you
to not rush it and to first prepare it
now the King if you can get King c7 and
now you pushed upon and now again be
careful because if t 6 it's a stalemate
so here for example King eight what you
could try to do is for example I
actually I'm gonna ask you what you
should do I don't want to give
everything else so let's say for example
in this position after King ate so
basics would make a stalemate
what how do you think white should play
and there's an app for endgame training
oh great
I used to do a lot of different
applications too so yeah I agree with
bringing the bat that came back but the
King c6.r King b6 because if King b6
than King b8 King a6 King could go to a
eights maybe so that's just something to
think about
okay so I'm getting King b6 which i
think is correct because it forces
everything King b8 he just played King
a6 King AIDS and now the King has to go
away which is ideal
next we make tickly so yeah just be
careful with this little little traps
yep great all right on to the next one
okay so this one is black to move this
is again something very basic
understanding of the square so whoops so
this the the easiest way to think about
it is this like there is this square if
the King isn't in it then white will
manage to easily make the pawn promotes
to a queen and if the King isn't it then
the pond will be taken so basically it's
about black being on time so basically
by any any of King d6 d7 or d8 actually
does draw the game so let's look at King
d7 for example you push and very simply
the king will be in the square again
it's one of those really easy concepts
but when the position gets a slightly
more challenging then it's kind of hard
for you to completely know about it
hopefully I will get to the positions
that I have prepared that are a little
bit
tactical as well okay so this one is
white to move now we're getting to the
concept of break through I earlier
mentioned breaking the concept of break
through and I talked about it more is in
the sense of just pieces Kings pawns
anything so one way that you can think
about it is this is one of those ideas
of break through so now you're combining
the ideas of opposition and that square
and now you're putting it in work to
idea of break truth so
yep let's see some suggestions
thank you I like talking you want to end
games
so yeah so far I have two different
loops and yeah so you do have to think
about both of these moves both a 6 and B
6 who are worth considering and if you
already know the idea of breakthrough
you'd know that B 6 is the winning move
simply because after take a 6 and the
king just can't get into this oops
the King just can't get to the square
fast enough so that's easy to think
about and the difference is if you put a
6 first now there is king d7 and I do
believe that this is still winning
because of p6 take a 7 but just B 6 is
more accurate and it would be a good
practice for your future references
because okay right now the king is
really far in Kingston 6 urgency it
wouldn't work but there are different
other positions that similar ideas you
would have to be very very accurate in
order to be able to actually get the
full point so yeah b6 is the most
accurate one all right see what else we
got
okay this one is will like to move and
the main idea is about tubes one because
right now if it's is why to move the
pawns are all kind of stuck together so
why should have to take the king back
same for black if it's black to move
black would have to move the king but
the problem is if you play king c6 13 e5
if you play king d6 there's king c5 so
so far the ideas that we've seen are we
talked about the opposition which is one
of the main ones we talked about the
square to breakthrough and the zoosk
walk
in Rio King you would most likely have a
combination of all of them but it's
really important to be able to use those
two for example trick your opponents
because for example let's think if this
was white you move in this position you
could think about how to trick your
opponents because why to move you would
have to bring you a king back and for
example whoops let's say you would bring
your king back and this is one way that
you can trick your opponent with
triangle and the same idea if you are as
black and you know that your opponent is
going to try this triangle is that you
would also try and hold like a triangle
so it's like these two squares are kind
of poisoned so as soon as the King goes
to D for you it has black he would
ideally want to place your King to d6 so
you can't you won't let the opponent's
come in C for every 5 and same for white
you would want see your king to be ready
so if black goes to king d6 you would
play king d4 so I think it was poisoned
poisoned squares so yeah I think they
have a better name I've seen in
different books but I mean it's poison
so oops
all right well it's kind of different
depends because if it's white job
White has the chance to kind of try and
trick the opponent with the triangle but
if the opponent makes all the right
moves and it's a draw so now the the
technical term for what we're about to
see is called squeeze so this one is
still very doable but I'm not
I'm Scott Elias who used ideas that
we've seen so far and combine those and
ideally give me a full line with whites
and black moves so yeah be right here
oh yeah mine mean squares mine scores
all right have trouble for not sending
it but
yes this is white Ameth so if I forget
to say whose movie this I'm accident
usually just look at some ooh this if
the first line is one or eight if it's
AIT's means that's well it's bottom of
if it's one why'd you move
well yeah how many's pretties he's right
and he already said his his rating is
almost 2100 so well he is right no
wonder he can say all of these so yeah
basically you should play King d6 you're
gonna tying your opponent's hands ok
squeezing and ideas that opponent can't
really move the king because if you move
the king I will just take your pawn and
if you try to push the pants I will just
keep keep the pressure on your pawn on
c5 and just continue to wait until you
run out of moves so basically you get
into 6:1 and now I first eat your Queens
icon and then I'll simply go and push my
palms and depending on what you do
because even if you manage to get this
somewhat called ex-teammates you can
just come and take the other pawns
and this is winning because for example
let's say we play very recklessly and
just keep pushing upon which you
shouldn't but the good news is that you
have this move
ready so yeah I got another suggestion
for first move g4 I think g4 is also
very interesting but it's it's slightly
more accurate if you just keep pushing
the movie with the king so you keep both
of the palms
cause you don't want to exchange them
off the board
and yeah well I'm glad I'm getting so
many suggestions alright let's jump next
one this one is black sumo I flip the
board so this would be the eighth rank
right now so this is again about
opposition but a little bit more
advanced and the simple just king one
final King so please give me a line for
this one
okay so I'm getting suggestions of h4
and possibly King g6 or cap six
well first of all do you think white can
win this game I mean do you think black
can hold this game
okay so we have a lot of people thinking
black and hold alright let's see so I
had the first of all I think it's should
be king of five and after king of
streaking the e5 because as black you
would want white to push these pumps so
if white pushes these pawns it's a good
thing for you because you can try to
keep holding a position and if the the
pawn is in front of the king that's a
good thing
you just keep the opposition and this is
gonna end in a stalemate so why
shouldn't push the pawns and so whites
should keep playing with the King and
now after King g4 King gap 6yt can try
to bring the King in a little bit more
and now what do you think do you think
it's to still draw or whites can't win
and preferably give me a full line if
you think it's a draw how do you think
it is with which moves that what you do
and if you think it's white winning then
give me the best moves for black ways
in this position black actress plays
King f6 so it's white to move
so you think wait hold on it is white
enough in this position
let me flip the board if it makes it any
easier okay so yeah Paul is correct
h4 should be and yes white does win
because H work in g6 King comes to e5
and you try to hold down your fort but
after losing to both of your pawns the
h1 and Japan will actually be good
enough to win this game for whites so
thank you for participating okay I'm
gonna wait a second if anyone has
questions and if not we'll just move to
the next one
so this one is White's to move and it is
a physician but it's a little more I
want to say advance than usual it was
not to draw the last one because it was
winning we're gonna go back because I'm
just getting any questions
due to the Delaine so the problem is
black did play the best moves so this is
the beginning position these are the
best moves that black is trying to force
whites into pushing the pants black is
holding their position and the key thing
is this h4 because white has that extra
Tempe and you would have to play king g6
cuz otherwise were anywhere else that
you go with your king king g5 would fall
so let's say King goes to g6 and you
would have to go back and even if you
keep trying to keep the King whitening
away from the g5 squirters king of six
and why to eventually get this oh so you
are asking about first Mouse h4 okay so
H bar GeForce should be the is the only
move
candy tree
is this demo I'm looking at scan
change-making 8th Street 6 can be 2 to 7
the problem is White's King is really
really close give me a second to think
about this
now the problem is even with Queen g3
this wins let's say you have to play
still check King here King e2 you make
cleans mates
yeah
the problem well for example if the
White King was very far away or even
slightly farther away
yes this would happen draw but White
King is really close on at the end this
kinky to helps White's win so yeah
all right let's go to the next one okay
so this one is white you move it is
again the same concepts of opposition
and everything so
preferably give me a full line
I'm reading a question about mmm not
promoting tonight while queen against
night will win
regardless so even if you would make
tonight I could just play king
II won in that position for fragrance
enthusiast nice if you remember the
position I could just play King you on
and your night and you're still in the
kind of long you move the night I can
meet you or take the night so okay for
this position
yes Paul you are right and are yeah so
a5 king b7 and king these six so what if
King goes to b8 k c6 king a7 king b6 so
you are applying the same methods that
we used on the previous game and this
one so great
thank you all for answering so this one
it's just the idea that like this
doesn't matter whose I'm sorry depending
on whose move it is if it's white to
move why it's gonna move this king and
lose the pawn if it's black to move
black cast over the king and lose the
clown so it's just an idea so now we are
gonna talk a little about barriers this
one is black to move and as you can see
Black has one more pawn but everything
is kind of stuck this c4 pawn is
protecting d5 square at 465 square so
you kind of have to be very creative on
how and if you can actually break
through so
yep please give me a line and the
suggestion for who's gonna win or what
was the results gonna be good chess
books well it kind of depends what topic
you're working on for openings for
tactics for end games because for for
example one of my favorites things to
just do is to just get strategy books
and the ones that are just books with
commentary like tournament games
commentary and I would just read
overdose and I would learn opening the
endgame the middle game all of its so I
kind of like that one of the ones that I
really liked was wanted to go fun to get
off on drugs to books I don't know the
third one came out yet but he wrote some
books about defense and attack and those
stuff and those those are really good
another thing one of my other favorite
books is the Fisher's 60 memorable games
because he wrote it and he explained it
in his own words about his games so that
was pretty cool for me
thank you Nixon I I might knows
okay so I got some suggestions that this
is going to be a drop because you simply
can't break through any yes that is
correct
so this is the only logical way black
could try to want to bring the King in
which doesn't work because white is just
in time to block alright so now we're
getting into the concept of tempo were
spare tempo so now this is again blacks
mouth please think about what move would
you want to do as black since you have
that positional shouldn't be that hard
to find but yeah
okay so we are talking about c6 great
I'm glad everybody agrees on that so the
idea is after c6 why it's kind of stuck
it doesn't matter why what why does why
I was going to end king d3 king at four
if King goes to every King d4 and
pompoms and the rest we've already seen
how easy it can be to win all right next
one
okay so this one is somehow a mix-up
everything you've seen so far so please
take a second and figure out the line
and give me the line
so hopefully you all can see it
ok so I'm getting ideas of white wins
and the main work that we're thinking
about is b5 alright thank you but
preferably give me a full line like b5
what should black to you and then what
would Y to at least three four moves
because it's endgame so it should be
easy to look at for both colors ok so
the idea yes
hop IT is to create a passed pawn and go
eat the others yep that is - GLaDOS
corrects
so b5 take take and then we've seen simp
something similar to this before and you
would just go it's pretty much all of
the plants you you were right
thank you so now we're going to talk
about how important it is to have an
outside passed pawn so it should it's
also is has the shares the same idea
that we just saw in the other puzzle so
preferably just give me a line quickly
so we can go to the next one and see as
much as King and pawns possible so just
remember having a passed pawn outside
passed pawn in an endgame special king
empowerment game is extremely important
yep I am getting ideas already a five
and you would kind of distract the king
and take
[Music]
initiative over here get your king far
enough so you can push your Jeep on and
yep
yeah they're goal set by fragrance
enthusiast so yeah you just gonna
distract it and then shoulder away when
the Queen comes couldn't have said it
better myself
so this one takes a little bit more
calculation even though it's less pieces
so this one is black still off and
please tell me who do you think what do
you think as the results gonna be and
ideally aligned
okay
just a heads up in about ten minutes we
are gonna switch to tactics
okay so I'm getting the idea of king d4
and black wins here right does everybody
agree on dads
okay so another great line from Paul
King before King eats you correct
King c3 is the key move and so you're
kind of just keeping the King away
shouldering it's basically shouldering
yep shoulder way so after King III you
get me five first it's important not to
take the king first because then you
would your pond kind of get stuck this
is still winnable just enough to play
King a4 and just be careful to first
play b6 so you have an extra Tempe
moving forward for example you can play
b5 and bring the king in and the rest
should be easy enough to do and we've
done this before and yay all right
so this is called the the faint I I'm
sorry this is white to move so for me
the idea is kind of clear because you
want to try and keep your pawn as long
as possible and take that try and take
the black's pawn but I really don't want
to give out the move so
okay so we're thinking black wins but
it's white so preferably give me um give
me ideas on what white should do
okay so first up should be king a six
can anybody tell me why alright great so
f king g6 yep if you take King G five
I'm gonna take your pawn away so if you
push b4 what about before
yep so if if before you get a five and
you boats managed to make Queens just in
time and this is going to be a drop all
right thank you everybody who gave me
ideas and participated okay so this is
supposedly called out flanking and this
is Black Sea move you can see how
advanced black spawn is but at the same
time how dense white King is so what do
you think is going to be the results
so it just blacks your move
so you think what's going to win
interesting
preferably give me a line so we can we
can go over that line again this is
Black Sea move
okay so we are talking we're talking
about king of five king of seven and
King at five right so the King kinder
has to go to a seven King g6 can you
eight king of six King do seven and so
yes the problem is you lose the d6 pawn
and you can't keep it and eventually all
of those pawns fall so yep
so you all were correct this is winning
for whites and simply because early on
what the eventually this d6 pawn is
going to fall and it's not going to be
you can't it's kind of impossible to try
and bring the king all the way to the
others part of the board would be very
nice but very it's really unrealistic
because let's say you play King c7 and
you just can't just you're not going to
be in time so yeah wise is winning and
you're fine knowing at the lovely
triangle dad's we talked about
triangulation I think that's it yep okay
so this is why to move and please give
me a line
okay so we are getting suggestions of
king c3
then king d2 is another suggestion and
king eater so these are the three main
suggestions so the the thing that you
should realize is that you want this
exact same position just black - so
black would have to break the position
and move the King so the correct move is
King Gd - indeed and the problem is
black has to keep the king or in these
squares because if King D quarters b6 so
after king d6 you play king c2 because
black can't play king c6 and then you
get King c3 so now you are getting the
opposition and this is how you win so
you did a position you did the
breakthrough and now you're gonna take
the other pumps so this one's gonna be I
think our last puzzle before we moved to
tactics are we switching okay so please
give me line for this one this one is
supposed to be called underpass so that
should give you an idea and make sure to
look for the taxi class that's gonna
happen just in a few minutes after this
one so yep
all right so most of the people are
agreeing on King f2 king d6 King g3 if
King g5 we have an idea from Paul to do
the King ish for and I think Anna and ha
meet so yep pretty much everybody got it
all right I am glad that I had around 80
viewers thank you for tuning in we are
gonna switch to tactics but it's we're
gonna end this video and start a new one
I believe yep
so what so yeah just stick around then
make sure to watch that one I have some
cool tactics with timers on everything
so yeah I'm gonna sit here